il y à des discours qui marque au
parlement même si nous parviennent de
loin à travers un écran
volodymyr zelensky l'acteur devenu héros
de l'ukraine et des démocraties
occidentales est apparu peu avant midi
dans un endroit gardé secret
jouer devant une salle comble il a pris
quelques minutes pour interpeller
directement les canadiens
pouvez vous imaginer demande-t-il qu'à 4
heures du matin chacun d'entre vous
comment s'entendre des bombes des
explosions
pouvez vous concevoir qu'une arme et
établisse un siège autour de vancouver
et que tous ses habitants restent
coincés à l'intérieur de la ville c'est
ce qui se passe en ce moment mario paul
explique-t-il
pour le président c'est lenski et le
canada doit en faire plus pour aider
l'ukraine et 5 lui l'imposition d'une
zone d'exclusion aérienne au-dessus du
ping ce cri
combien de missiles de plus doivent
tomber sur nos villes avant que vous ne
preniez cette décision lance-t-il aux
parlementaires
et parlementaires qui ont bien sûr
saluer le courage du président
dirigeants courageux et exceptionnel
chaque match
mais qui après le discours n'ont pas
voulu s'engager à abattre des avions
russes qui pénètre dans l'espace
ukrainien l'objectif est de ne pas
déclarer
un conflit international donc une
troisième guerre mondiale seuls les
conservateurs ont ouvert la porte et
pour protéger le ciel au dessus des
routes empruntées par les civils qui
fuient leur pays on demande aux
habitants de prendre les moyens
nécessaires pour que au moins on puisse
protéger les corridors humanitaires une
démarche qui pourrait mener à une
escalade croix de chef du bloc c'est un
risque on ne peut pas se permettre de
prendre je peux prêt à me réfugier
d'arrêt mon rôle de parti d'opposition
pour demander quelque chose qui
sembleraient à ce stage irresponsable et
françois blanc cette demande toutefois
au gouvernement trudeau d'accélérer la
cadence dans l'accueil des réfugiés des
annonces en viennent promet la ministre
mon objectif est de pouvoir justement
années s'est réfugié là donc les
conversations en lieu et on va pouvoir
en dire
plus super
c juste trop long avant que vladimir
zelensky ne s'adresse au parlement
canadien vladimir poutine avait déjà
préparer sa réplique justin trudeau
mélanie joly anita annan et presque tous
les députés aux communes sont désormais
persona non grata en russie ici le
remporter radio canada ottawa
l'attaqué survenue à l'aube alors que
kiev dormait encore une fois des
immeubles résidentiels ont été visés par
les tirs russe
j'ai été réveillée par le bruit de
l'explosion dit ce jeune homme ma
première pensée a été de me dire tout va
bien je suis encore vivant au milieu des
décombres des personnages et des blessés
des morts et malgré la cruauté de ces
attaques qui cherche à briser le moral
des civils les moments d'humanité
côtoient les moments de bravoure
l'intensification des tirs sur kiev a
amené le maire de la ville a décrété un
couvre-feu
nous vivons des moments difficiles et
dangereux dit le maire de kiev pour
votre sécurité je vous demande de rester
à l'abri pour les 36 prochaines heures
peut-être dans l'espoir d' entraîner une
désescalade le président ukrainien qui
ont compté annoncé qu'il renonçait à
intégrer le temps
nous ne pouvons compter que sur nous
mêmes et sur nos partenaires qui nous
aident at il déclaré
devant l'ampleur de la dévastation
les ukrainiens continuent de fuir leur
pays par milliers
et signe que la crise s'installe dans la
durée les premiers enfants arrivés en
pologne ont commencé l'école et qu'ils
préféraient quoi les je ne comprends pas
toute cette fillette mais je suis
contente d'être ici dans une école
normale
une façon de reprendre le fil d'une vie
brisée un jour à la fois ici lice
villeneuve radio canada montréal